[country rock music]
- It's been about--
over 20 years
that I've had this truck.
Never had a chance
to lay a hand on it
and try and get
anything done.
To be out here today
with Rick,
working on this truck,
finally--
it feels really good.
- Hey.
How are you doing?
How's it going?
- Going all right.
- Okay.
- Little slow going,
but think we're getting it,
a little bit.
- We're out a little more
than we should be.
Okay, let me see
the hammer you used.
Okay, so the hammer head--
see the hammer?
- Mm-hm.
- See how it's rounded
like that?
- Uh-huh.
- And which dolly?
Okay.
This dolly is good
on the inside...
- Mm-hm.
- But this hammer
is not so good on the outside,
'cause all it's gonna do--
see how it's got, like,
a round corner?
All it's gonna do
is punch holes.
It's gonna make more divots,
more holes.
So you want a flat head,
where it's really flat
on the end,
and then,
when you're hitting on it,
you gotta feel where it is.
Okay, I'm high here,
so I'ma put the dolly
right behind there,
and I'm gonna tap it.
[loud tapping]
And you want that--
you want to go up and down.
♪ ♪
Let me get over there.
So right now,
especially with my body man.
He is--he likes the Bondo.
I hate the Bondo.
I wanna metal-finish it.
So, I mean, you've got it.
It's looking good.
There's j--you saw I was
just barely hitting it, right?
But that little bit of hitting
will allow that 1/8 inch
of extra Bondo
you would put in it
to--you won't have to.
You did good.
I mean, you can feel this,
right?
Feel this, nice and flat.
Feel that,
and then feel that.
♪ ♪
- Yeah.
- And i--
- I can feel some ripple in it.
- Yeah.
- There's a little bit
of stuff, right?
So all you're gonna do now is--
this one here,
I think we need to pull
all the way out,
and then we need
to just sand it,
you know, and it'll--
it'll eventually be
the same thing, and then
all you gotta do is
you prime it.
You get it all metal-finished.
You just prime it.
There's no material on it
at all,
which is the best way,
believe me.
It's important to have this
all nice and smooth.
It's got some lumps in it,
but we're getting there.
- Got a little bit
of work left to do.
Did a lot of work today.
Hopefully, he's happy
with my work,
and hopefully,
I don't set him back
too far on timeline
with slowing him down,
so...
♪ ♪